good afternoon everybody
thanks for joining me here yet again um
we're coming in the home stretch here
the counties have been working
incredibly incredibly hard
hundreds of thousands of ballots have
been counted so far today
and we're in very good shape um but
there's still
still some to count so they are working
incredibly hard they're going to keep
counting into the evening
and you know stay tuned so
um let's see we have
uh we've been reaching out we've been
very closely in touch with all 67
counties
making sure that they're reporting on as
regular basis as possible
i know all of you everybody around the
country around the state are
are eagerly awaiting and i can tell you
the counties are too
they are really taking their time making
sure that
every single voter in the commonwealth
who has cast their ballot
is having those ballots accurately and
securely counted
so um you know as you know um
we're going to keep counting military
and overseas ballots i think
are coming in those will continue to be
accepted through next tuesday
there are obviously provisional ballots
that will have to be counted as well
after the initial round of ballots and
you know i think whatever whatever the
outcomes are
i can tell you that i'm so proud to work
with
the 67 counties the election officials
who are just
doing an amazing job getting these
counted accurately and securely
so i am happy i think with that
to take your questions yes the integrity
of the election
has certainly been questioned quite a
bit over the past several days and it
seems to be intensifying now
in these final states that we're waiting
to hear from
what is your message to the people of
pennsylvania and
the people of the country about the way
things work here in pennsylvania
so you know as we've been talking about
for months
pennsylvanians have more choices on how
they've been able to vote this year
than they've ever had in the history of
the commonwealth and no matter how they
voted
what's critical here is that we have
very strong processes in place
that make sure that that voter in that
voting integrity
and security are constantly
constantly followed by every county in
the state so for example we talked about
i think it was yesterday voting by mail
in pennsylvania
so the process is we thought though
though it's new under act 77 that we can
all vote by mail it's the same processes
that we've used for decades for absentee
voting
so voters have to apply they're checked
against either social security database
or the penndot database
they're checked against their voter
record to make sure they're qualified
voter and they are who they say they are
they cast their ballot and then they're
checked again when the ballot is
received that they were actually
an approved voter very secure
there's there's really like the strength
of the integrity of this vote
is really unparalleled same when you
vote in person right you have to be
registered you go in
you sign in the poll book all these
things are tracked our
voting systems and our databases
make sure that no voter can cast more
than one vote
it literally has a hard stop should
anybody even try and the counties
again as i've talked about the amazing
county election officials
they take this so seriously they are
such professionals
so you know it i can just say really no
matter how you chose to vote this year
and so many pennsylvanians have and it
looks like it's really going to be great
turnout
when we finalize the numbers that every
method is incredibly safe and secure
yes
sir hi secretary hey you've said uh if i
if i understand it correctly that enough
results may be coming in tonight for
people to have a
handle on who the winner in the
presidential race is
what's your basis for thinking that can
you put a finer point on it how long
what makes you say that so the counties
are the counties are continuing to count
and so obviously depending on how close
the race is
that impacts whether you so you know
the the final results are not certified
until 20 days after the election right
so i want to be clear
there's no final results happening now
anyway what's happening now
is having enough ballots counted to
actually see who the winner is right the
farther apart that is
the easier it is to tell so it's very
close
in pennsylvania right there's no
question and so
that means it's going to take longer to
actually see who the winner is
how we get to the con
conclusion but you know either way i
want to be clear
that these are just the male and
absentee votes and the in-person votes
right the overwhelming majority like
i think you know a huge huge majority of
the
in-person votes have been counted we're
in a very good place with the mail and
absentee ballots
but not quite there yet but then there's
going to be provisional ballots the
military and overseas ballots and so
forth so the closer the race is
the longer it takes but i think what
i've said all along
is that the overwhelming majority of
ballots will be counted by friday
i still think that we're ahead of the
schedule and we actually already have
counted the overwhelming majority of
ballots
but because it's a close race it's not
quite clear yet who the winner is so
yes you've mentioned provisional ballots
a couple of times
um how many of those have been cast
statewide
and of those how many have been counted
and reported
so very few have been counted and
because the
that usually happens following the
counting of the other ballots so
usually so that you won't see counties
are not going to start that
until after they've finished with the
others generally um
so so we don't know yet we've been
reaching out to the counties i know i'm
the camera reverse you or somebody else
who asked me both about provisional
ballot numbers and
numbers of ballots arriving after
election day after epm on election day
so provisional ballots you know i think
we've heard from
you know maybe two-thirds of the county
so i don't have a
firm number yet and as soon as we do
we'll be able to report
those numbers can you give me your best
estimate
the provisional ballots i think it's
still early yet
so let's touch base again after i have
more than the number that i have so far
yeah no guesstimate at all it doesn't it
you know the context the context matters
right so if i tell you a number that
ref reflects 41 counties it's not it's
it's could not it could be not
reflective of the whole because it
matters which counties they are
so we will circle back with you yes
oh you sorry i know that you stand by
the integrity of the election so far
have you or any of the counties
investigated
any specific allegations of voter fraud
no no i mean i'm not aware of any i mean
well i should say
you probably heard some weeks ago
that there was a gentleman in lucerne
county who tried to apply for a ballot
for his deceased mother
i don't know if you heard that but that
that was that was several weeks ago
um that was the only incident that i am
aware of
in this in this year
yeah yes sir um i know that you said a
minute ago that you guys
counted the vast majority of the
in-person election day votes
can you give us a more specific sense of
how many of those are outstanding is it
fewer than the remaining mail-in votes
oh yeah if you
go to our website and the supplemental
dashboard
if you look at like the pie chart it's a
tiny sliver it it may be the 99
or count it so if just but i whether
it's 99 or 90.5
go to the dashboard and it will tell you
more beyond the male in balance
no i mean there's a tiny fraction of
precincts that aren't counted yet
yeah it's it's a very very very small
number yeah
yes the outstanding of mail-in ballots
does that include counties that have
said
have all counties segregated the ballots
that came in
after election day right so the
um the ballots that have been counted so
far
are the ones that came in by november
3rd
so and all the counties are going to be
segregating any
that came in after 8 pm on november 3rd
through
5 pm on november 6th
yes yes secretary there are seven
precincts in allegheny
county that aren't reporting anything
yet that includes
uh election day in-person ballots do you
know what's going on there
no i don't but i'm happy to check with
them afterwards
they and i mean i know what's going on
some of the other things but i don't
know what's going on in those seven
precincts so thank you we will reach out
to them
yes does the department know how many
mail-in ballots might still be enroute
to election offices that
were postmarked by the third do we know
how many are enroute
no um you know i could tell you that um
the numbers that have come in so far are
a tiny fraction of what came in after
the primary
so i don't i don't think and usually
based on historical numbers you get the
most
ballots you know the day after election
day and then it dwindles from there
so i think it i don't expect it to be a
significant amount
were surrendered at the polls on
november 3rd not yet
we will know that because the we will
know that you know
at once the counties do those plans
because obviously those voter
declarations had to be signed
and i think they'll also be able to
track the provisional ballot voters the
ones that didn't
surrender their ballots so but that will
take some time thank you
yes uh have you and your staff taking
any safe
special safety precautions and uh should
the uh
county workers who are doing the
counting be concerned about their safety
given the
strong feelings
so by safety you mean from the outside
world or
physical safety yes you know the
counties really have the are in the best
position to assess that i mean as you
might imagine
you know we're we have a great
commonwealth very
a lot of diversity from you know very
rural
counties to urban counties so it's
really not a one-size-fits-all
assessment
we certainly talk to the counties and
issue guidance and directives on
security of you know the voting systems
and the locations
and you know all those things but i
think the physical security of the staff
i would defer
to to the counties on what about you and
your staff
taking any special precautions yes
i mean we have security we make sure
that we are safe and we make sure that
where where we are where operations are
are secure and safe
yes thank you yes yes i was going to ask
you about the
late arriving ballots if you have any
kind of kind of idea of how many there
are but
based on these questions i get a sense
you don't know but you did tell cnn
today that it was anywhere anywhere from
zero and some counties to
hundreds and others so i mean can you
give a little bit more
yeah i mean again it's it's it's
actually it's a it's a lower note it's
significantly lower number than we
thought but i think we've
we've heard from i apologize i forget
exactly how many counties so it's not a
full picture yet but it's a much less
less significant number it's like a
fraction of what we saw in the primary
so i think we saw
60 000 in the three days following the
primary
it's not going to be anywhere near that
um so
once i have the full again i think i
have maybe
you know two-thirds of the counties and
so i just want to make sure before i
give
but what i said was was true it's been
there are some counties that got zero
the day following and there are some
counties that got in the hundreds
you know maybe 500 but so that's the
range that i have now but i just don't
want to give an overall picture until i
make sure i have every county in
thanks but it really is smaller yes
if i could just double back on mail-ins
uncounted valence i think you said in
your opening remarks that there were
several hundred thousand
outstanding and we've heard some you
know varying numbers on that can you
put a finer point on that at all what
kind of figure we're looking at
so go to go to the website and go to the
dashboard
it's constantly changing and so it just
seems like as soon as i give a number
there are county results that get
updated and it's different than what i
just said it's a moving target what's
the last number you were aware of
um i think it was in the 300 000 the 350
000 range
but again as soon as i say that you're
going to go into the dashboard and it's
going to say it's lower than that so
i can thank you for indulging yeah sure
yes
so on election night results in
lancaster county were
showing an amount well above the amount
requested and then nearly double the
amount return could you explain why that
happened
and if that was county specific i'm
sorry can you repeat that again yeah in
lancaster county on election night
specifically
it was showing results for mail-in
ballots that was well
above the amount returned and the amount
requested can you explain how that
happened
you know i can't remember lancaster
county specifically what i can tell you
is that some of the counties the way
so and lancaster i'm thinking it
probably had to do so they're
one of i think the two counties that had
heart have heart voting systems
some of the each voting system vendor
has the way they translate with the data
has worked slightly differently and as
you know this dashboard
and even the website it's the first year
that we broke out
provisional ballots mail and ballots and
in person so
some of the reporting if the county's
files
were not done perfectly it might merge
to the categories it might put things in
the wrong category
so we've been working on all those
quirks um like i know for example york
was off for for a little while but that
is now corrected
so that may have explained what was
going on with lancaster um
there's just been it's most of it has
been the county the way they sent us the
files
the data was just not in the right place
basically
that it was handled and taken care of is
there is there a way that you can do
that
well it's fixed i mean it's fixed on the
website and you can also so
i mean i i think i've said this prior
priors of these but
you can always go to the county websites
you can look and see
you know it's it's an easy way to double
check
yes dennis secretary some some tweets
have surfaced admittedly from a couple
years ago
your tweets suggesting negative things
about donald trump what do you say to
people that say
geez you're the person overseeing this
election and you have clearly partisan
views on the matter
what's your response to that so my
response is look these were four years
ago
and at the time i was not in the
administration i was not in any public
service i was a private citizen it was a
personal twitter account
um and you know i so
so that and then when i became secretary
of state
i took an oath dennis and i took an oath
to defend
and and protect the constitution of the
commonwealth of pennsylvania and the
constitution the united states
and partisan politics have no place
in the pennsylvania department of state
or any county elections office for that
matter
may we work for voting rights
and for effective election
administration and i can tell you that i
will do
everything in my power to make sure that
every voter
every candidate and every party have
access to a fair free safe and secure
election
and i don't care what their background
is and i don't care what my background
is
that's what we do at the department of
state thank you
you